biologists have long marveled at the  complex social behavior and insects now  a team of roboticists has managed to  mimic the foraging strategy of  leaf-cutter ants the team used computer  simulations of small robots whose  behaviors evolved over time the robots  start out with just a few simple  behaviors like moving and grabbing  objects but they're not pre-programmed  with instructions on how to retrieve the  green blocks and bring them to the nest  at the bottom of the slope gradually  small changes in the robots programming  cause some of them to stumble onto  productive behaviors at the end of each  simulation the robots that performed  well are more likely to go on to the  next round eventually a system develops  some robots drop blocks from the top of  the slope and others collect them at the  bottom this is the same system used by  leaf cutter ants  you